[Aplausos]
[Música]
2020 se acabó y nadie lo echará de menos
la pandemia del cómic 19seg o durante
ese año oficialmente la vida de 18
millones de personas alrededor de todo
el planeta 2020 fue simplemente un año
terrible sin embargo espera un momento
porque os aseguro que al menos una
comunidad el pueblo saharaui no recordar
a 2020 precisamente como el año del
coronavirus
[Música]
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos las cosas se han puesto
muy pero que muy feas por el que hasta
hace medio siglo era territorio español
en el mes de noviembre el ejército
marroquí intervino en un área de
desmilitarizada a que un principio
estaba bajo control de la misión de paz
que la onu tiene desplegada sobre el
terreno por supuesto la reacción del
movimiento nacionalista de los saharauis
el llamado frente polisario no se hizo
esperar anunció que daba por concluido
el alto el fuego que había oficialmente
en la zona desde 1991 año en el que se
les prometió un referéndum de
autodeterminación así que todo indica
que un conflicto que no nos engañemos
estaba latente anestesiado pero que
estaba ahí se ha reactivado en 2020 30
años después y amigos y la situación se
estaba complicando por sí sola lo cierto
es que aún quedaba por llegar el golpe
de gracia
marruecos el frente polisario y que más
pensáis que podía entrar en escena no es
apuestas porque se pagan muy mal fijaos
hoy firmé una proclamación reconociendo
la soberanía marroquí sobre el sáhara
occidental' la propuesta de autonomía
seria creíble y realista de marruecos es
la única base para una solución justa y
duradera para una paz y prosperidad
perdurable es el reconocimiento de la
soberanía marroquí sobre el sáhara
occidental'
pone todo un impulso un salto de gigante
las ya de por sí tradicionalmente buenas
relaciones entre los eeuu y marruecos
así que ahora las preguntas que podemos
hacernos son en qué situación queda el
sáhara quien busca eeuu al reforzar sus
lazos con el reino alauita y tal vez la
pregunta más importante de todas cómo
puede afectar el apoyo norteamericano a
las tesis de rabat en la política
regional del norte de áfrica e incluso
un país vecino como es españa queridos
amigos hoy el visual político vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
alina en una suma millonaria green y
laia nube coming soon el magrebí y la
realidad
la marcha verde
[Música]
el sacra occidental ocupó una gran
extensión de terreno en el noroeste de
áfrica el problema es que como su propio
nombre indica pues la zona es bastante
desértica así que durante siglos pues
apenas tu interés para nadie
así fue de hecho hasta que a finales del
siglo 19 los españoles establecieron
allí una ciudad portuaria villa cisneros
como bien sabéis en áfrica era la época
del colonialismo más pero así que los
españoles no quisieron quedarse atrás
reivindicaron también como propios los
territorios del interior y durante 90
años se reconoció internacionalmente la
soberanía de españa sobre todo el sáhara
occidental' quien vive allí bueno
saharauis un pueblo nómada sin apenas
asentamientos les preocupó acaso la
llegada de los españoles pues no porque
bastante tenían con sobrevivir en el
desierto además los españoles se
limitaron durante 50 años a permanecer
en las costas así que a la hora de la
verdad pues molestar un poco los
lugareños más tarde en tiempos de la
dictadura del general franco los
españoles comenzaron a explorar el
subsuelo en busca de recursos naturales
pero por más que buscaron petróleo no
encontraron ningún yacimiento
interesante ahora bien como ya os
contamos en un pasado vídeo que os dejo
la descripción los esfuerzos españoles
no fueron inútiles
[Música]
bien
españa descubrió en 1963 en el sáhara
occidental' el criadero de fosfatos de
bucraa los fosfatos son sales del ácido
fosfórico que se emplean en la
elaboración de abonos minerales muy
demandados por la agricultura el
hallazgo del yacimiento de boukra enorme
y fácil de explotar supuso una
importante competencia para el principal
exportador de fosfatos en el mercado
internacional marruecos
claro que para entonces españa ya tenía
otros problemas por un lado el comité
especial de descolonización de la onu ya
había incluido al sáhara occidental'
como uno de los territorios a
descolonizar y por otro comenzaron a
surgir movimientos nacionalistas
saharauis dispuestos a luchar por su
independencia
es precisamente ahí cuando surge el
frente polisario que entre otras cosas
se empeñó en boicotear el funcionamiento
de la mina de bucraa y vaya si lo
consiguió en un primer momento el
gobierno de españa' entendió que esto
era así como haber guardado el cofre del
tesoro durante décadas y que justo ahora
que acaban de abrirlo pues se lo querían
quitar sin embargo parece la represión y
los enfrentamientos iniciales al final
españa accedió a que en 1975 se
celebrara un referéndum de
autodeterminación para lo cual claro
comenzó a elaborarse un censo sin
embargo la marcha verde lo cambió todo
el 6 de noviembre de 1975 hassan segundo
ordenó el desplazamiento de 350.000
civiles a la frontera sur de marruecos
para que iniciaran una marcha destinada
a ocupar la colonia española sólo de
lucha
brutal y purines y de lucha no se trata
una orden alfabético pues ya tenemos una
hora en el médico pues es una tarde me
manipula y
a pesar de la condena de la onu a la
marcha verde su éxito fue inmediato ocho
días después de iniciarse se
materializaba el acuerdo de madrid en el
que españa se desentendía de la
administración de la colonia y dejaba
que marruecos y mauritania se repartiera
en el territorio
de esta forma españa abandonó
definitivamente el sáhara de febrero de
1976 momento en el que el frente
polisario proclamó la república árabe
saharaui democrática y emprendió
entonces una guerra contra los invasores
con resultados desiguales fue exitosa
contra mauritania que pronto se dio
cuenta de que no valía la pena luchar
por el tercio sur del sahara con el que
se habían quedado así que mauritania se
retiró en 1979 pero amigos la alegría
saharaui duró menos que un charco de
agua en el desierto ya que la zona fue
inmediatamente ocupada por marruecos
ocupar en sáhara occidental' fue de
hecho el mayor éxito de hassan segundo
por ejemplo quedarse con bucle reafirmó
su posición de dominio sobre el comercio
mundial de los fosfatos y buenos y el
autoritario con sus súbditos marroquíes
a los que reprendió duramente en los
años de plomo pues imaginaos contra los
saharauis no se cortó un pelo en usar
cosas como napa lo fósforo blanco lo que
motivó por cierto la huida saharaui de
los campos de refugiados ubicados en
territorio argelino tampoco le tembló el
pulso a marruecos para atajar los
ataques de la guerrilla del polisario
levantó por ejemplo la berma un muro de
arena de ocho tramos diferentes que
totalizan 2.700 km fortificados con
búnkeres bayas y campos de minas aun así
los enfrentamientos entre ambos bandos
continuaron
900 la onu consiguió en 1991 un alto al
fuego basándose en la promesa a los
saharauis de celebrar un referéndum
hasta entonces el territorio del sáhara
occidental' quedaría oficialmente bajo
supervisión de la minurso una misión de
naciones unidas en cualquier caso la
berma dejaba un statu quo muy favorable
para marruecos dos tercios los más
importantes del sáhara occidental
estaban dominados por marruecos el
tercio oriental el más inhóspito bajo
control el frente polisario
y así han ido pasando los años sin que
el referéndum se celebrara marruecos ha
hecho lo que le ha dado la gana le
sáhara incluso hasta conseguir una
carretera que llega a la frontera con
mauritania y esto motivo por cierto el
incidente del pasado noviembre en el que
los saharauis pues hicieron una sentada
para cortar esa carretera alegando que
su desarrollo era ilegal claro que
finalmente intervino el ejército
marroquí para acabar la protesta por la
fuerza
algo que el frente polisario pues ha
interpretado como un acto de agresión
que le obliga a poner fin al alto el
fuego y desde entonces lo cierto es que
hay mucha confusión sobre todo lo que
sucede en esta zona porque por un lado
marroco silencia en conflicto y por otro
pues que os voy a decir el frente
polisario emite unas partes de guerra
que son tan propagandísticos que
directamente son imposibles de creer y
queridos amigos así estaban las cosas
cuando además en diciembre intervino el
presidente de los eeuu estoy hablando de
donald trump
[Música]
abraham lincoln
que eeuu y marruecos son buenos aliados
no es algo nuevo en 1777 el sultán de
marruecos mohamed tercero se convirtió
en el primer líder internacional en
reconocer la independencia de los
estados unidos de américa incluso estos
dos países llegaron a firmar un acuerdo
de amistad que sorprendentemente en
cierta forma continúa vigente hoy en día
más de 200 años después para que os
hagáis una idea el consulado de eeuu en
tánger fue la primera la primera
propiedad adquirida por el gobierno de
los eeuu en el exterior ahora bien un
momento la decisión detrás de reconocer
la soberanía marroquí sobre el sáhara
occidental' va absolutamente en contra
de lo que ha sido la política
estadounidense al respecto durante las
últimas décadas así que la pregunta a la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es por qué
demonios lo ha hecho tan preocupado
estaba atrás por las tensiones entre
marruecos y los saharauis pues como os
podéis imaginar no para nada nada de eso
reconocer la soberanía marroquí sobre el
sáhara es la recompensa de la casa
blanca a esto marruecos es el último
país en normalizar los lazos con israel
en un acuerdo negociado por eeuu amigos
los países árabes solían considerar que
aislar a israel era una buena forma de
apoyar a los palestinos en sus
reivindicaciones hasta el 2020 apenas
dos países árabes tenían relaciones
diplomáticas con israel sin embargo
desde el pasado septiembre este número
se ha elevado hasta los seis viajes
entre otras cosas al impulso dado por la
administración trump a los llamados
acuerdos de abraham hablamos de una
forma de entender la diplomacia muy como
decirlo una diplomacia en la que todo
absolutamente todo es susceptible de ser
negociado a cambio de normalizar
relaciones con israel emiratos árabes
unidos por ejemplo recibió el permiso de
washington para acceder al mejor avión
militar del momento el caza f-35 así
como drones avanzados dentro de una
compra multimillonaria de armamento
estadounidense y por su parte de sudán
también recibió asistencia financiera y
logró ser eliminado de la lista de
estados que patrocinan el terrorismo lo
que pasa es que con marruecos trampa han
mostrado su peor versión de hombre de
negocios porque donald para llegar a un
acuerdo con rabat pues no hacía falta
tanta recompensa
[Música]
marruecos siempre ha mantenido
relaciones amistosas con israel pero
discretas e informales 250.000 judíos
vivían en marruecos cuando en 1948 fue
fundado el estado de israel' muchos
fueron emigrando al nuevo estado lo que
hace que en la actualidad un millón de
los habitantes de israel tengan un
origen marroquí eso ha supuesto entre
otras cosas que cada año 50 mil
israelíes hicieran turismo en marruecos
los tiempos pre pandemia a pesar de que
su vuelo se detenía durante 30 minutos
en malta para sostener la ficción de que
no había vuelos directos entre ambos
países
según los medios de comunicación el
trato entre washington y rabat fue así
de simple
'israel por el sáhara occidental' nos
cambiamos las cartas pero amigos lo
cierto es que ahí no termina todo aún
hay algo más por ejemplo sabemos que
trump siempre estuvo atento a los
intereses de la industria armamentística
pues bien en octubre se hizo público que
marruecos tendría acceso a los f 35 y un
día después un día después de que el
reino alauita anunciara que iba a
normalizar sus relaciones con israel se
supo esto exclusiva la administración
trump avanza en el acuerdo de venta de
armas con marruecos por valor de mil
millones de dólares ahora la duda es que
ahora la administración bailén desde el
momento en que asuma la presidencia lo
que queréis que os diga lo más posible
es que no cambie nada a los que mandan
en washington seguramente les preocupe
más no hacer un desaire a marruecos que
atenderán las reivindicaciones de los
saharauis por los que por cierto hace
años que nadie mueve un dedo para que se
celebre el referéndum prometido
[Música]
por supuesto eso no quiere decir que no
haya habido voces críticas contra la
decisión de tras la más autorizada la
encontramos en jean hijo veteranísimo
senador estadounidense del partido
republicano por oklahoma que salió en
defensa del pueblo saharaui en unas
intervenciones en el capitolio
sting y fermentos de edad behring ley de
raids de vuestro espíritu
pero esperada porque esto aún no es todo
a pesar del reconocimiento a su
soberanía sobre el sáhara y el acceso a
la última tecnología militar
norteamericana parece que el rey mohamed
sexto que es quien controla la política
exterior de marruecos aún le faltaba
algo más digamos que todavía tenía dudas
unas dudas que según el 'new york times'
la casa blanca hizo desaparecer por
completo poniendo papeles sobre la mesa
papeles sí pero verdes y con la cara de
washington franklin y lincoln la
administración trump estaba dispuesta a
echar una mano facilitando hasta tres
mil millones de dólares en inversiones
en marruecos gran parte de las cuales se
destinarían a bancos hoteles y una
empresa de energía renovable es
propiedad del rey quien dijo que trump
no apostaba por el cambio climático
incluso parece ser que el pentágono
estaría estudiando trasladar una
importante base naval que los
norteamericanos tienen en rota españa a
marruecos 2 de enero de 2021 anuncian el
posible traslado de la base de rota a
marruecos medios periodísticos del país
vecino lo dan por hechos y aseguran que
la instalación militar se situaría en el
sáhara
donald trump condecora a mohamed sexto
de marruecos con la legión del mérito
vale hoy parece complicado que esto
ocurra pero como veis marruecos podría
llegar a convertir
el aliado más estrecho de los eeuu en
toda la región lo que ojo porque a largo
plazo podría llegar incluso a tener
consecuencias sobre algunas de las
reivindicaciones de marruecos sobre
territorios españoles territorios como
ceuta y melilla claro que aún es pronto
para todo eso españa apoya los esfuerzos
de naciones unidas en favor de la una
solución política justa y duradera y
mutuamente aceptable que prevea la libre
determinación del pueblo de sáhara
occidental'
en el marco de disposiciones compatibles
con los propósitos y principios de la
carta de naciones unidas la amenaza a la
uita que se celebre un referéndum de
autodeterminación en el sáhara
occidental es una misión imposible
simple y llanamente de marruecos no está
dispuesta a renunciar ni al territorio
ni en los recursos naturales que puede
haber en la región por eso su última
propuesta fue la de que el sáhara 100
tae se integrará en marruecos como una
especie de región autónoma ahora bien
cómo se puede ser autónoma en un país
que está lejos de ser una democracia se
puede ser marroquí y al mismo tiempo
autónomo de mohamed sexto es evidente
que no pero lo cierto es que hasta la
onu parece haber tirado ya la toalla
respecto al referéndum de
autodeterminación que por otra parte
pues tampoco sería en nada
adelante
el referéndum nunca ha llegado a
realizarse por el desacuerdo entre las
partes sobre quién tendría derecho a
votar
el frente polisario aboga por el censo
español de 1974 que establece quiénes
son los saharauis sin embargo marruecos
aboga por dar voz y voto a los
habitantes actuales del sáhara
occidental' a donde lleva décadas
trasladando a parte de su población a
base de incentivos subvenciones y
exenciones fiscales resultado la
población de origen marroquí ya es
mayoría en el sáhara
para nuestros culpables
descartado por tanto que haya un
referéndum en sáhara occidental' va a
seguir en manos de marruecos casi que lo
mejor que les puede pasar entonces es
que continúen las buenas relaciones con
israel porque pues ni más ni menos
porque israel es líder mundial en
tecnologías agrícolas y tiene una amplia
experiencia en trabajar sobre
superficies desérticas de hecho uno de
los mayores artífices de este acuerdo a
tres bandas ha sido un destacado miembro
de la comunidad judía en marruecos
hablamos ni más ni menos que del
empresario del sector alimentario nariz
elfa del canal ministro de asuntos
exteriores marroquí más ser bonita y con
negocios en israel ya sabéis no todo es
política habitualmente estos acuerdos
pues esconde tras su business
gigantescos un business que se suma al
que implica el rearme de marruecos lo
que de por cierto pues no es nada nuevo
rabat lleva años adquiriendo tanques m1
abrams cazas f-16 obuses autopropulsados
m109 etcétera etcétera como decía él en
parque jurásico no han reparado en
gastos informe el 91 por ciento de las
importaciones de armas de marruecos son
de fabricación estadounidense
precisamente ante esos hablábamos de un
nuevo acuerdo valorado en mil millones
de dólares un nuevo acuerdo que
proporcionará el reino alauita 42
avanzados tipo sky guardián m
con un alcance de 11.000 km una
tecnología que permitirá marcos barreira
amplios territorios en el mar y en el
desierto es decir para que nos
entendamos además de reconocer la
soberanía sobre el sáhara trasladando
los medios a marruecos para hacer
plenamente efectivo su control y si me
da que en el frente polisario ya han
pillado el mensaje y también los dos
países con los que limita el sáhara
occidental y que defienden la causa
saharaui
mauritania y especialmente argelia que
se iba fatal pero mal mal con marruecos
y muchos os preguntaréis y qué hay del
otro vecino de marruecos que dice de
todo esto tiene ojos de la onu sigue
siendo la potencia administradora del
sáhara occidental porque considera que
el acuerdo de madrid carece de validez
jurídica pues amigos la buena noticia
para los saharauis es que aparentemente
cuentan con el apoyo decidido del actual
vicepresidente segundo de españa y líder
de la extrema izquierda pablo iglesias
por ejemplo esto es lo que decía cuando
no era parte del gobierno los saharauis
no son solamente nuestros vecinos del
sur son nuestros hermanos
y a los hermanos no se les abandona un
nuevo ejemplo del divorcio entre la
casta política y los intereses de la
mayoría de la población porque la
población española es pro saharaui pero
quienes nos han gobernado parece que son
pro negocios esa es su única parte claro
que un momento porque ahora pablo forma
parte del gobierno español y en este
caso la mala noticia para los saharauis
es que mientras rabat se está gastando
una millonada miles de millones en
rearmar en el ejército marroquí pues en
españa el gobierno de pedro sánchez y
pablo iglesias hace cosas como estas el
gobierno dota a marruecos con 10 6
millones de euros en material de
vigilancia para reforzar las fronteras
la frontera con el polisario quizás
porque amigos marruecos hará lo que
quiera con el material total nada nuevo
bajo el sol ya en 2005 el gobierno de
rodríguez zapatero vendió a marruecos
por un precio simbólico una veintena de
carros de combate m60 para que fueran
desplegados en el sáhara occidental'
además en españa ya nadie habla de este
territorio porque entre otras cosas ya
se encargó ramas de lanzar la cortina de
humo más adecuada el primer ministro de
marruecos sobre ceuta y melilla son
territorio marroquí cortina de humo
seguro en fin amigos así están las cosas
por el momento pero
ahora la pregunta es para ti vamos a ver
con todo el efecto dominó que han
provocado las decisiones de tram en la
región quién pensáis que al final serán
gran beneficiado y el más perjudicado
creéis que el rearme marroquíes para
reafirmarse como el gran poder militar
del norte de áfrica o que se están
preparando para actuar contra otro tipo
de enclaves por ejemplo para apoyar sus
reivindicaciones políticas sobre
territorios españoles amigos podéis
dejar vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre es este vídeo
se resulta interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like i suscribiros a visual
política si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho una vez más muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo a la próxima
estamos preparados
el territorio link